[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia en france 24 mi nombre es
álvaro cordero el 12 de julio de 1962
hace exactamente 60 años un joven grupo
de rock and roll británico decidió hacer
su debut en el mítico market club de
londres su nombre era the rolling stones
y en ese momento no eran conscientes de
que estaban a punto de cambiar la
historia musical del planeta para
siempre sus satánicas majestades tienen
a sus espaldas 30 álbumes de estudio han
vendido más de 250 millones de discos y
en pleno 2022 siguen actuando y llenando
estadios para cientos de miles de
fanáticos en france 24 repasamos su
historia
[Música]
the rolling stones nació como un
proyecto musical de dos amigos de la
infancia llamados mick jagger y keith
richards a los que les unían su amor por
el rock and roll figuras indispensables
que junto con artistas como brian jones
o charly watch formaron una banda que
marcaría la cultura popular en la década
de 1960 su música triunfó en reino
unido- y arrasó en eeuu catapultando los
al éxito
[Música]
sólo vinimos aquí la primera vez para
darnos a conocer y luego cuando volvimos
empezaron a pasar cosas para nosotros
durante sus primeros años los rolling
stones se mostraron como los chicos
malos del rock and roll por su aspecto
desaliñado y su lenguaje y respetuoso
algo que contrastaba con the beatles
estas dos bandas marcaron a toda una
generación que buscaba cambios políticos
y sonidos nuevos durante este periodo es
donde se encuentran algunos de sus más
célebres trabajos como ay can get no
satisfaction paint it black o simpatía
for the the world canciones que pasarían
a la historia pero junto a la fama
llegaron las polémicas los excesos de
algunos de los miembros de la banda con
las drogas eran mundialmente conocidos
algo que hizo que brian jones uno de sus
miembros más icónicos tuviera que
abandonar la banda en 1969 y que apenas
un mes después falleciera en una piscina
con tan sólo 27 años pero más allá de
los altibajos si algo caracteriza a los
stones es su capacidad de resiliencia en
el tiempo ante los cambios algo que les
permitió adaptarse a las nuevas
corrientes musicales que empezaron a
llegar a partir de los años 70 y 80
mientras que otras bandas de su tiempo
como the who o the beatles se
disolvieron ellos continuaron sacando
trabajos adelante y aunque sus nuevos
álbumes no lograron la fama y el
reconocimiento de los primeros su
popularidad siguió por todo lo alto
[Música]
al final de la década de 1980 el grupo
vivió su peor momento para ese tiempo la
juventud del momento comenzó a seguir a
otros géneros musicales alejados del
estilo de los rolling stones y esto hizo
que sus integrantes comenzaron a
trabajar en álbumes en solitario una
cuestión que alejó a mick jagger y keith
richards e hizo que la banda no diera
una gira por más de siete años pero
lejos de desaparecer su fama mundial
aumentó con la llegada de los 90 sus
rentables giras congregaron a cientos de
miles de fanáticos de decenas de países
con independencia de cuestiones
políticas o ideológicas un imperio
comercial que incluso les hizo dar uno
de los conciertos más multitudinarios en
la historia al congregar a más de un
millón y medio de personas en la playa
de copacabana en río de janeiro en el
año 2006
[Música]
[Aplausos]
su puesta en escena es una de las claves
de su éxito a pesar de los años la voz y
los bailes de mick jagger los solos de
guitarra de keith richards considerado
uno de los mejores guitarristas de la
historia o la potencia que impregnaba a
charly watch a la batería han hecho que
sus directos fueran reconocidos por su
calidad durante décadas y que ninguno de
los miembros de la banda se haya
planteado retirarse
estoy seguro de que me retiraré pero no
estoy ahí disfruto de lo que hago no me
preocupa cuando me detendré esto fue una
decisión que nos ha llevado a estar
activos por seis décadas convirtiéndose
en la sociedad musical más longeva en la
historia su aniversario llegó después de
una dura noticia para el grupo la muerte
en 2021 de su batería charlie watts algo
que no ha impedido a mick jagger keith
richards y robbie gut los 3 stones
todavía activos volver a salir en una
gira de homenaje a su carrera que
llevará su rock and roll por todo el
mundo les dejamos escuchando uno de sus
conciertos de la gira del 2022 gracias
por compartir y comentar historias que
las encuentran en los programas de
france 24 punto com
[Música]